you like this I'm back in my bedroom
again because yes I got rid of the
office no I do not is still there I just
feel like this is natural I'm gonna get
more connect in there you know what the
problem is with having equipment in your
room everybody thinks you're shooting a
porno I wonder what my poem will become
it's not the size of the boat it's the
immigrant that comes along with it Oh
what is going on you two back in my room
again now if you haven't heard already
there's been a little bit of drama in
the kingdom of home recently do a leak
take through a security cam there was a
video of jay-z getting the [ __ ] beaten
out of him by none other than the lodge
no yes I would
that's right Beyonce's younger sister
and I gotta tell you something
I'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] cracks me up so much
maybe it's because it's a testimony that
you can always have money but that [ __ ]
don't erase crazy now of course we all
don't know what really happened because
there wasn't any sound on the videotape
but if somebody sucked you like this
you must have done did some [ __ ] but you
know what the funniest thing about this
clip is is Beyonce's reaction that's
right she had no reaction
I wonder use of other cuz you leave
everybody else to die god damn she
straight up just move to the side and
diss even pretend like you go help she
brought me good one of those I'm
sounding like I'm gonna help you but I
don't know that's all you got [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just wait till we get home
this will got 99 problems and it's a
lodge is one listen all you got to do is
sock JC
in his lips because that [ __ ] cannot get
any bigger than it already is JC the
only rap on her they got a zip code for
his lips jay-z's lips Oh big duffle with
a lifetime supply a Carmex personally
for me I just want to know the
conversation he had with Beyonce when
they got home no I can't be the only one
but get it just me or do I think that
Beyonce and jay-z talk to each other
only in lyrics
let me cater to you cheer you got
punched in the face Oh baby are you okay
hey what you think [ __ ] now here's the
thing that you might have to realize
jay-z but instead some offensive or
crazy [ __ ] to get his ass beat like that
you know how I know this
her finisher move was a [ __ ] leg kick
let me tell you something in a fight you
don't kick somebody unless you're Asian
are you [ __ ] crazy
how much you want to bet he whispers
something filthy to her hey you got a
fat ass so lies you are officially one
of the very few people that has actually
beat jay-z's ass and you did it publicly
but I gotta give you Jay because the man
kept his cool baby bear ladies you may
not know this but it is the most
difficult thing to figure out what
you're supposed to do when a girl is
going ham on your [ __ ] face now
personally for me I was taught to never
lay a hand on a woman but let me tell
you something if you come swing at me
understand you put a line in the corner
you might get you titty bit off now I
ever put my hands on a woman
now but one time she slapped me I'd
pretend the trip and I crunch the
kneecaps
into a fine baby powder that's why I
said says she was a crib yeah you a crib
now a [ __ ] crippled [ __ ] what now if
I were jay-z and I would be yourself
about her I would never lay my hands on
her good job Jane but I
[ __ ] would fart the hell on the elevator
huh that's right you didn't know I play
chemical warfare [ __ ] i suffocate you
that's right put you directly on my ass
cheek an atomic bomb the [ __ ] out your
face oh that's so wrong I wasn't going
on YouTube chilling what am I doing with
it thank you all for tuning in I just
felt like boiling something randomly
today and yes as you can see I'm back in
my bedroom I don't want to be the office
anymore it was a little bit too I don't
know a PVC end but now I'm back you know
I feel like it's a little bit more
person but you guys get to talk to you
you know as obviously I just stick you
later more than I should what's up but
yes of course there will always be a
video on Sunday and if there's a lot of
topic that you want me to talk about go
ahead to the fanpage leave it there go
on my Twitter edit there go my Instagram
let me know what's up
holla at me Hana Hana Hana Hana Hana but
I will see you all next time and of
course at this Sunday so peace out
everybody what's good but no wonder you
were so far right survival was at the
bottom no wonder you at the bottom [ __ ]
that's what that oh I just spit what
just try to move to the side and she
didn't even that amount HIV